hey guys I've received so many video
requests on how to be more attractive
how to be more successful in life how to
improve your clothing style and even how
to be cooler in life
there are a lot of people who want to
improve themselves for the right reasons
and other people for the wrong reasons
now if you want to improve yourself as a
man for the right reasons then there's
nothing wrong with that because that's
the only way how you will stand out and
influence this world to become better
other people to become better so
improving yourself is not just about you
it's about other people it's about
improving yourself so that you can make
a difference for everyone who lives in
this world and if you want to do that if
you want to stand up you need to accept
four important things one never fear
group pressure dare to be different
two stand strong for your beliefs your
values and Never Back Down
three you will receive criticism if you
go against the crowd four you are in a
spiritual Battle of Good and Evil light
and dark
there are many people who just go with
the crowd even when they know the crowd
is wrong
think about this there are many good men
doing absolutely nothing because they
are afraid because of group pressure
they don't want to stand out they don't
want to say anything and that is why
there is so much evil in the world
Edmund Burke said the only thing
necessary for evil to Triumph is for
good men to do nothing
now listen to me today if you want to
stand out because you want to impress
other people because it's about you you
want everyone to view you as wow this
guy is so cool he's got so much money
he's got a perfect car he's got a nice
house the greatest girlfriend he's got
everything oh look at him and then you
feel so good about yourself if that's
you then you're focusing on the wrong
things
material things as passing away and it
means nothing at the end
I realized this when I lost my second
brother I was focusing on the wrong
things
that didn't bring anything to anyone
trying to get rich drinking partying and
living to impress other people
while they did nothing to improve the
world nothing to improve my life or the
lives of others I'm being very honest
with you guys I was just wasting my life
are you wasting your life right now
by focusing on the wrong things
you are not going to take your money
your clothes your car your PhD or your
job with you when you die you came into
this world naked and you're gonna go out
of it naked you're not going to take
anything with you and what are people
going to say about you when you die
you know there are 150 000 people who
die every day and people think that
they'll only die when they reach 80. and
then they are shocked when they stare
death in the face
both of my brothers when they died
they were in their early 20s
there is no value in living this life
selfishly
let me say it again there are 150 000
people
who die each and every day
one of these days
one of them might be you
Albert Einstein said try not to become a
man of success but rather try to become
a man of value
this is how you stand out as a man in
this short temporary World Albert
Einstein he was a smart man but he's
dead
but his words live on so let me ask you
when you die
what are people gonna say about you will
they forget about you will you just be a
nobody
or will you stand out for all the right
reasons even after death
if you want to be a man of value if you
want to stand out then you need to do
the following things one choose the
light and live in it so that you can see
the darkness for what it is that means
accepting God into your life
2. seek more truth every day grow in it
live in it and share it three never fear
people's criticism if you know what you
are doing aligns with your values and
beliefs
four fight for what is right not just
for you but for all people
five use your limited time wisely by
scheduling your priorities and focusing
on what truly matters
6. build friendships with like-minded
people iron sharpens iron
seven keep your eyes on your goals
whatever happens
eight be a great father a great son a
great brother and a great friend
nine be selfless for where jealousy and
selfish ambition exist there will be
disorder
10. listen to understand because only a
fool takes no pleasure in understanding
11. leave your ego behind reckon it as
dead because if you think you are wise
then you need to become a fool so that
you can become wise
12. always be ready to sacrifice things
in order to achieve the right type of
goals
13. never boast about yourself but let
your work and other people speak for you
14. let your brain and body always work
at 100 by eating healthy and by
exercising 15. never gossip and never
judge someone until you know the full
story
16. always give more than what you
receive
17. choose the righteous path even when
it takes longer 18. always control your
emotions so that it does not control you
19. be the bigger man and never waste
time on endless quarrels with fools
20. never be overcome with evil but
overcome evil with good think about your
life seriously
what are you doing with your life right
now
if you want to improve if you want to
become a man of value if you want to
change and truly impact the lives of
other people and watch these videos here
from my other channel and I'll see you
there and always remember life is short
so don't waste yours cheers guys